i mean i feel like maybe the starting
point is reincarnation it's the you know
us as souls and i know that past life
regression was something that your dad
did for you and that you
started doing yourself um soon after um
so maybe with that like what you know
explain reincarnation explain how we
come into this body
in this
point in time
in this family with all these things
like how does this whole process work
from death to rebirth
all right we got five hours so yeah
i'll uh i'll sum it up so yeah so my
kind of beginning
uh
consciously to get into all of this
stuff
was was past life regression
and
okay so i'll bring it like super macro
and then i'll bring it super micro so at
a macro level like in the entire
universe you've got source frequency
source energy some people call it god i
just call it source
um
and
source is unity it's all it's everything
and nothing it's light and dark
and source decided to
split itself off many times over and
incarnate into singular versions of
itself so if it's all the colors in the
rainbow it's like i'm just going to be
red for this lifetime i'm just going to
be yellow and the reason why source
decided to go back to the beginning go
back to the nothingness is because they
wanted to learn it wanted to experience
it wanted to grow
and that's kind of where we come into
play and plants and animals and all of
that have a piece of source have that
soul
we're all experiencing different lessons
so the whole point of life in general
getting away from all the conspiracies
and the agendas is really just to be
here to learn to experience to grow to
get challenged to move forward there's a
really pivotal conversation that i had
with source itself many years ago and
the question i asked is like
you know i get asked this question all
the time why is there so much suffering
like why if you're this almighty all
knowing all omnipresent thing why would
you allow that
and source came back to me to say
okay
imagine you had access to everything in
my 3d world all material possessions all
friends all great dynamics all knowledge
all information all anything you could
ever possibly imagine you had it all
and source said all right elizabeth how
long would it take for you to get bored
i'm like yeah not long if you have it
all where do you go from there and so
source decided to kind of reverse itself
and to split itself off and so if you
imagine like i believe there are 12
dimensions in this universe and that of
course there are many different
universes
and every dimension has a certain
vibrational frequency to it the lower
dimensions are further away from source
further away from infinity or
unconditional love frequency so they're
more singular they're more linear and
then the closer you are to source and
the higher dimensions the more a part of
source you become um in that way and so
if you could imagine like just in a very
plain way every dimension there's a
thousand lessons that you have to learn
in that said dimension you incarnate a
thousand times or sometimes it takes ten
thousand incarnations to learn
i know those people or what have you
um you learn what you need to from that
dimension and you move on to the next
one now i originally thought upon
receiving that information okay
dimension one dimension two dimension
three dimension four
my linear mind perceived it as that then
i started doing past life regression for
people and i'm like
you were an 11th dimensional angel in
your past life like in your very last
lifetime what are you doing as a third
dimensional human and i started to
realize that it doesn't go one two three
four five
you go wherever you need you are needed
to experience that lesson
um
yeah so there is a difference in souls
on this planet at this time which is
super unprecedented and very very very
unlike any other third dimensional uh
terrestrial planet out there typically
third dimensional planets have third
dimensional souls
period like that's even though it
doesn't have to be that way that's
typically the way if you're presented in
a reality that contains this much or a
certain amount of energy your soul is
going to match that much energy it's
like fitting a you know a round peg into
a round hole that's essentially what it
is um this planet is obviously different
there's a huge shift that's taking place
we're this massive peace treaty so we
have
bad influences we've got these shape
shifters we've got these dark entities
and however we also have all of these
other beings who are choosing to be here
at this time
so the galactic federation said all
right we kind of messed up you know the
reptilian beings are on planet earth
they're manipulating human beings what
can we do to help and they went through
a lot of different things to try and
help humans i'll name two of their
attempts and then i'll name the third
one which is actually what the success
was the first thing that they really
tried was
let's just go greet the humans in our
true form and tell them that there's so
much more than this and that they're so
powerful that they can do it you know
and all of a sudden they're like
an angel from the sky came to greet me
let's write a bible about it i must
indoctrinate more people you know into
this limited frame of belief um or they
were deemed crazy and unfortunately they
got persecuted for having these
experiences or they became some sort of
religious leader and totally took it out
of context so that strategy did not work
um the second strategy that they uh
tried and they've tried many these are
just a couple
is they're like let's go ahead and
manufacture a vibrational grid around
the planet that every human being is
connected to so it's kind of like a mini
it's almost like we have our mini sun or
a mini source but it's kind of like a
grid all around planet earth and that
helps me connect to you even without
words you know all across the planet and
uh there's actually been a couple of
different really cool studies that show
that we are connected in an unspoken way
um so they manufactured that and that
helped to a certain extent uh and we
still have this consciousness grid
around planet earth today which is
getting more and more activated which is
really cool
um they're they're
the other thing that they tried that
really started to work is they're like
okay
if the humans won't
listen to us
or they do listen to us and they
misinterpret us because we're so
different because we can fly and float
and we come down in ships or we look
different or what have you
let's just go ahead and be the human
maybe they'll listen to their own kind
wink wing nudge nudge yes that didn't go
over so well so that's when the galactic
federation started to look for
volunteers
hey beautiful beings of higher
frequencies do you want to go on an
adventure of a lifetime
come on down the planet earth it's going
to be really fun you know and so like a
roller coaster yeah
the ups and the downs like just imagine
jail you know
but that's you know and it was really
tough to find volunteers from the
galactic federation as you could imagine
why would we leave all of this and go
down there
you know but that's what they needed
they needed
they needed individuals who had a higher
natural vibration to come to planet
earth to teach the humans while being a
human
and this started to work like this
technique was the first one to really
make a huge impact um and that's kind of
how
uh you know starseeds got born and so i
always say star seeds and when i
reference star seeds it means that your
soul is not originally
from the lower dimensions it's not
originally from planet earth it's
actually from much higher dimensions and
you came to incarnate and volunteer to
be here as a human the problem that
happens what percentage of people are
volunteers then
um
it
to increasing it's been increasing i
would say at this point in time
around
i don't know it's hard to say i would
say between 10 to 20 percent got it okay
which is actually a huge number of
people yeah it is you know yeah and so
and i think it's the numbers are
increasing and more more starseeds are
increasing here
so this is what maybe dolores cannon was
speaking about about the three waves of
volunteers right and they're kind of
have their own sort of end sort of
characteristics but there's been three
waves of volunteers and the most recent
are really the crystal children that
already have the upgraded dna that you
know are growing up right now
absolutely yeah okay totally
okay and
you know it's it's so fascinating to
meet a being who's never been to this
planet before
and they're just so bewildered and
excited and sometimes super apathetic
and they're just like they're so over
stimulated they're so overwhelmed with
everything that's taking place that they
don't know
uh they don't know where to go right and
like
so i call it a
a starseed a syndrome starson syndrome
is basically where they're just floating
along life they they don't really have
any passions because it's just too
overwhelming for them to be here and
this is where we get into imprinted
lifetimes which i believe is the new
uh the new 5d version of
volunteers coming to planet earth is
why would you want to live out all of
these dense human lifetimes of suffering
and challenge and the middle ages which
were awful um when you could just
download all of those lifetimes it's
kind of like reading a book and saying
all right i've read the the how to human
guide for planet earth because i've
downloaded and imprinted all of these
past lives and now i've got enough
skills to come to planet earth with and
me as a past life regressionist
especially at the beginning of my career
um it was very difficult to tell the
difference between what lifetimes are
imprinted and what lifetimes are real
and there's a whole few like flurry of
issues uh when we're getting into that
because if you get a random flashback of
a past life of you getting persecuted
and you believe that you really lived in
that lifetime then just by believing
that was truly you you could create
karma around that the whole point of
past life imprinting is of course you
get to hop over the space and the time
of actually living through the lifetime
but you also come to the planet with
zero karma because you took zero of that
action in those lifetimes that you're
imprinting you come with a very clean
energy center
what what what would you tell people if
they were gonna but let's say someone
was about to lose someone what does that
mean oh lose someone like that yeah yeah
yeah like yeah you die like what happens
then
yeah always come back is you always come
back as a human
or you don't always right you go other
places but you don't die essentially
your energy doesn't die
yeah no definitely not so i do like i
used to do with clients a lot of um
one-on-one work and a lot of mediumship
uh and so i would actually follow the
soul through the white light tunnel so
that's not all a thing like you hear a
lot about um like near-death experiences
and it's all very similar to that when
you
pass away
um you have a choice to make and do i
have unfinished business and do i stick
around or do i move on
and when a soul decides to stick around
but their body ends up passing away
then they're kind of in this weird lemon
liminal realm so the way that i see it
because i kind of go to them is it's
kind of like they're just in a dark room
and they're full of emotions and they're
full of fears and they're full of
attachments and what happened and what
if and i should have and why not and all
of these regrets and because of that
emotion that's unresolved or the
attachment that's unresolved they end up
getting stuck there and we can interpret
or see them as like a ghost like they're
a spirit and and the dark room that
they're in could be the house that they
passed away in and then they're attached
to that house and they don't really know
that they're attached and they don't
know that there's another way
so
that's when i can come in and say hey
you know
like let me hear your story what do you
what information do you need to get out
in order to feel like your soul is
relieved enough to cross over then i'll
go ahead and cross them over some
individuals have such a lighthearted
energy they're like i know that i've
been you know slowly
decaying for a while and i'm prepared
for death and when their body
passes away their soul goes right into
the light and they end up crossing over
and that's where their friends and
family members and spirit guides and
everyone is there to greet them and it's
a huge celebration and all of their
heaviness and fears and regret from the
past in this lifetime go away instantly
and then there's a period in time some
souls take longer than others where they
have to review their lifetime it's like
the lifetime review yeah it's like these
are the decisions that you made and
these are the people that you impacted
and and so i don't believe that there's
a heaven and a health like in a
religious sense but i do believe that
there's
higher and lower vibrations that you can
experience afterwards eventually a soul
will choose to cross over they're not
stuck there indefinitely they will when
they're ready when they're ready they
will cross over to the light and then in
that place after you've reviewed your
lifetime and you figured out what body
do i want to be in next what incarnation
do i want to experience what challenges
have i yet to experience and then you
get put into the incarnation that best
serves your highest vibrational good
sometimes you're a tree like people
don't realize that we can be a tree we
can be an ant we can be a bird you know
in the sky
and so